[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el
17 de mayo se celebró el día
internacional contra la homofobia la
transfobia y la bifobia el mismo día
pero en 1990 la ms eliminó la
homosexualidad de su lista de
enfermedades mentales y el día oficial
se instauró para animar acciones que
denuncien la discriminación contra las
personas homosexuales bisexuales y
transexuales y que sus derechos humanos
sean garantizados
aún así 70 países aún criminalizan la
homosexualidad siendo el feminismo una
lucha transversal por los derechos
humanos y que acoge la diversidad ese es
nuestro tema de hoy
en san francisco está el primer barrio
transgénero del mundo la ciudad en
california eeuu reconoció formalmente al
lugar conocido como tenderloin que desde
hace 100 años acoge a la comunidad
sexualmente diversa este también es un
mensaje que recuerda que los ciudadanos
transgénero aún enfrentan discriminación
y violencia viviendo en un ambiente
difícil incluso en una de las urbes más
liberales del mundo
el distrito transgénero de san francisco
es conocido históricamente por acoger a
los recién llegados y también a los que
a veces caían en los márgenes de la
sociedad
[Música]
sofía es una mujer transgénero mexicana
que lleva dos años viviendo en este
distrito aunque afirma que el barrio a
veces puede ser complicado está feliz
esto es un paraíso y si está atrayente a
muchas mujeres y una de ellas soy yo
podría decirse que yo estoy una sólida
inmigrante mexicana que vivía en
carolina del norte y tuvo que
trasladarse a san francisco para poder
luchar por mis sueños poder hacer mi
cambio de nombre y poder conseguir un
estatus en este país la organización
detrás del distrito transgénero lleva
años ayudando a mujeres como sofía a
evitar la discriminación y la
marginalización ayudamos a la gente
transgénero a por ejemplo con este
programa de vivienda que acabamos de
lanzar hace como un mes y ayudamos a
gente transgénero
a poder cambiar su nombre en los
documentos de la corte
contratamos artistas para que hagan
murales
y diferentes cosas en la ciudad en el
distrito para hacerlo más bello entre
las actividades de esta organización se
encuentra a velar por el bienestar de la
comunidad incluyendo los sintecho
juniper recorre estas calles con las
otras integrantes de la organización una
vez al mes
si caminamos por las calles para ver
cualquier cambio en nuestra comunidad
para ver si hay algo nuevo necesidades
que hay que cubrir y cosas así intentan
echar
este barrio alberga una de las
comunidades más numerosas y densas de
personas transgénero del país en la
última década está habiendo amenazada su
idiosincrasia ante el avance de la
gentrificación
para conversar sobre la lucha contra la
homofobia y la transfobia está en ellas
hoy daniela brache ella es diseñadora
gráfica lesbiana y activista feminista
colombiana integrante de la corporación
caribe afirmativo que se dedica a
brindar espacios de referentes positivos
de diversidad sexual
daniela también hace parte de la
colectiva de mujeres lesbianas
bisexuales y trans raras no tan raras de
barranquilla bienvenida france24 daniela
y para entrar en materia primero quiero
preguntarle por el ejemplo de diversidad
que vimos con la nota de san francisco
si uno revisa guías para viajeros
encuentra que el barrio tenderloin a
solo minutos del centro turístico es
catalogado como el más peligroso de la
ciudad y lamentablemente este es un
patrón que se repite en todas partes las
personas transgéneros se refugian en
zonas empobrecidas o donde existen
círculos de violencia e inseguridad
háblenos de eso
sí muchas veces por estos prejuicios que
existen en estos en nuestra sociedad
contra las mujeres trans en especial
ellas se ven orilladas
a ocupar espacios de las sociedades que
quizá vamos solos más cómodos oa vivir
en lugares en los que hay altos niveles
de inseguridad y violencia entonces sí
es cierto que esta marginación que hace
la sociedad
pues especialmente de las mujeres trans
y las personas que generan trans en
general que sí influye mucho en sus
condiciones de vida y que se vean
empobrecidas con condiciones de salud y
educación
mediocres o incluso oportunidades
negadas bueno pues ahí tenemos un espejo
claro de lo que es la discriminación y
cómo puede afectar la vida y el
desarrollo de una persona usted dice que
el feminismo no puede ser sin las
mujeres trans ésta es una premisa de la
que quisiera que nos contara porque el
feminismo persiguiendo el objetivo de la
igualdad debe acoger a las minorías a
las disidencias porque necesariamente
debe ser transversal a todas las formas
de ser mujer
el fem y el objeto político del
feminismo como las mujeres en nuestra
diversidad no solamente las mujeres
blancas heterosexuales sino que además
nos incluye a las mujeres lesbianas a
las mujeres bisexuales y las mujeres
trans que sí bien
pues ellas viven ciertos tipos de
violencia diferenciada también por esta
presencia que existe en contra de ellas
también son víctimas de misoginia de
objetivización sexual de fertilización y
demás que si nos competen a muchas de
las mujeres en latinoamérica y en el
mundo entonces pues como bien dices yo
soy pues partidaria de que las mujeres
trans también son sujetos políticos de
feminismo a diferencia pueden tener
algunas corrientes fundamentalistas que
hay actualmente no solamente en
latinoamérica sino en diversas partes
del mundo bueno y como parte de esa
creencia usted hace esfuerzos también
desde la colectiva raras no tan raras en
la ciudad de barranquilla en colombia
cuáles son esos prejuicios contra las
mujeres
lb y por qué están mandados a recoger
sí muy buena pregunta
así como mencionas pues hago parte de
una colectiva
de superar las disensiones internos está
digamos que es una xuntanza nueva porque
generalmente las mujeres si quieren las
mujeres transgénero están separadas en
sus luchas y en los unos en su manera de
hacer activismo sin embargo nosotras
creemos que podemos hacer esta danza
colectiva
pues para esa lucha contra los
prejuicios y con las mujeres género
podemos acompañar a las mujeres trans en
esos procesos de integración social
por lo general las muestras están
estigmatizadas hacia el trabajo sexual
oa otros oficios como la peluquería
sin embargo en la medida en la que la
sociedad habrá espacios para ellas
y les brinde estas oportunidades que
actualmente les niega de educación de
tienda incluso y de estabilidad
emocional a las familias podemos tener
muchísimas más mujeres trans integrando
posiciones de gobierno en empresas
públicas y privadas que progresivamente
nos lleven a esta integración social de
la que te hablaba hace un momento
digamos que naturalizar su existencia en
las sociedades
mire en el contexto del día contra la
homofobia y la transfobia se prepara un
evento muy bonito en la región del que
usted hace parte intereses en movimiento
sobre mujeres l vete y funcionariado
público
esta es una capacitación internacional
para que precisamente funcionarios de
los países de esta región les den
atención a los ciudadanos sin
discriminar por sus opciones personales
o por sus condiciones de género o
condiciones sexuales venimos para
ustedes de sistemas de discriminación
estructurales que tan arraigados están y
como los estados y sus funcionarios
pueden combatirlos
si actualmente vivimos en las sociedades
donde la homofobia la lesbofobia la mi
familia transfobia
son rampantes de las vemos en diferentes
aspectos de la sociedad y las familias
como primer espacio que debería ser
seguro para nosotras muchas veces no lo
es especialmente para las mujeres trans
y esta cantidad de prejuicios que surgen
en el hogar y que también son
alimentados por diferentes imaginarios
sociales
llegar finalmente a la atención
gubernamental y que hacer las diferentes
entidades estatales entonces pues
tomando en cuenta pues que has
mencionado este evento importantísimo
que vamos a tener a principios del
próximo mes de junio 234 y queremos
hacer esta invitación a los funcionarios
públicos pues que también generan estas
rutas de acceso a la justicia pues para
las mujeres que desafortunadamente son
víctimas de violencias por prejuicio por
el motivo de su orientación sexual es
invertir de generar diversas
pues nuestra idea para este encuentro es
hacer este puente con el funcionario
público y hacer este intercambio de
experiencias positivas también que hemos
tenido de acercamiento
para que este acceso a la justicia y
pues esta reclamación de derechos pues
sea efectiva
usted y toma aspectos muy clave ese y es
que para las personas transexuales y
transgénero es muy difícil tener acceso
a salud a justicia a educación a
oportunidades laborales y por ahí
probablemente serían los aspectos claves
que deberían tener en cuenta los
servidores públicos ahora otro tema es
que desde que comenzó la pandemia
naciones unidas han reportado y han
documentado no solamente que empeoró la
discriminación sino que también
aumentaron los discursos de odio contra
las personas lgtb
qué opina de esto
y es extremadamente preocupante el
aumento de las cifras de violencia que
hemos tenido especialmente en este año
de pandemia en el que pues las personas
han estado confinados muchas veces pero
con sus agresores en casa y además pues
de la precarización del tema laboral
pues de las condiciones de vida de
muchas personas
por ejemplo el año pasado tuvimos este
deplorable caso de discriminación contra
una mujer trans
alejandra ocurrido en bogotá en el que
pues por estos prejuicios que y pues
también por su condición de vivir el vih
fue discriminada por los servicios de
salud mismo prácticamente pues fue
abordando armó nada son suerte para
morir en su hogar sin ser atendida
además de otros casos
de recrudecimiento de la violencia en el
cagüán honduras república dominicana
donde hemos podido ver esto
violencias y pues de casos contra
mujeres trans de la expresión
pues muchísimas gracias a usted por sus
impresiones y por contarnos estas
experiencias y nos queda simplemente de
conclusión que sin importar quién sea
donde se encuentre o a quien ame toda
persona merece que se le garanticen sus
derechos humanos siga con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]